[音楽]
panamera
たち共弘と申しますえっと私は折り紙の研究というのをしています皆さん折り紙って
いうのは一度は負ったことあるかなと思うんですけれども
売りカメ研究をしている人って言うとすごく少ないと思うんですねどういうことをやっ
ているのかということをご紹介したいと思います
まず
私がなぜおり画面を研究するに至ったかということをえっとですね
あのたどっていくとある作品至ります
でへと私は小学生の時にやって作品なんですけれども
こちら
はいこちらですねえっと前から13の悪魔という作品でこれすごい派と思って頑張って
彫り方を習って居るということをやっていました
でえっとこれは非常にあの位置複雑な形ですけども
1枚の紙から作られているものでし
でこれは非常にあの私のあの印象に残っていて
で今亀の視点から見ると特にこれで興味あるのは
これが
中身がどうなっているかということですねこの
造形の背後には
こういったパターンがありますこれ展開図と言って作品を
パッド1枚のためにまた戻した時にどんな折筋になっていますかということを示した図
ですねこれを見ると幾何的な模様に支配されて幾何的な出場があっあでこれは設計図な
んですねこの3次元の形を作るための設計図でその設計
頭というのを何か聞か的なパズルのような構成で実現していくとさっきのような作品が
作れると
これは非常にワクワクすることでこれはあの私の
えっと日
非常に強い動機付けになっています
でえっとで大学に進んだときにですね
私建築がにすんなんですけれどもその中で何か形を見るたびにはいろいろ創作をしてく
みたいなことをやっていましたこれも1枚の紙でできていていろんな話が作れるという
ことでいろんな創作をまあ
パンの建築で勉強する傍らとジョニーものめり込んでいましたこういうような
の非常に複雑な形でも立体的な形でもなんかが一枚の紙で作れるなということです
で
あの
こういうこれ風のをつくってみてこんなこと思ったわけですね
つまりどんな形でも作れるんじゃないのかなと
一番髪を切ることなく居るだけでどんな形でもスクリーンじゃないか
こういう疑問を異質といいですねこういう問いが生まれてきた
でこの問いに対する答えがえっとまぁ
いけるだろうと思ったのがこの作品ですこの作品は3次元のティーポットなんですけど
元々コンピューターでモデリングされています
そのモデリングされている切った異型成多面体として表してそれを忠実に一枚の紙で
折るという問題に
なります
で側ええっとん
忠実に居るためにどうしたらいいかということをいろいろ考えていくわけです
多面体にするつまり多面体というのはですね
三角形とか四角形とか単純な面がつながってできています
ただそのまま繋がったままですと1枚の紙にはなりませんね一度これをバラバラにして
しまえば良いだろうというのが考え方です
一度バラバラ
にするともちろん簡単に平面に展開しています
正しい面と面の間に隙間が出てしまいます
ですからこの隙間のぶぶを飛騨のようによってそれをお待たせ再びくっつけるという
ことを考えたんです
でへこの動画の方で見ていただくと5つある三角形が
キュッとお互いに近づいていってピタッとくっつくということがわかると思います
でここで着目していただきたいのはですねこの5つの三角形というのは一つの頂点を
共有しています
で5個の点があった s が一つの点に集まるということが起きています
でなのでこの折り紙を立体的に折り紙を作るという問題はいくつかの件があったときに
それを1個の手にまとめる折り方っていうのを考えるということに一つ集約されるわけ
ですそれを実現する実はそれってえっとそんなに難しい考え方ではなくて
まず一番簡単な例というのは2つ点がある
平面の中に2つ点があってじゃあこれを神様ってこの日に重ねてください切ったら簡単
にできますよね
ちなみにこのえっとおり線ってどんな折制になっているかと言うとこの2つの点を結ぶ
線分
この線分を垂直に2等分する線つまり水色に当分生ですねこれで構成されていると垂直
二等分線を使うとなんか2つの点がちゃんと重なるということになります
でえっとこれ今2点ですね2点をじゃあ3.2増やしたどうなるかということを考え
ます
実はこれはですね4ほんのり戦で折りたたんで3つを体を一転重ねることができるん
ですけどもその折のえっとおり戦のなかで重要な骨格みたいになっている部分というの
は実は先ほどの垂直二等分線を使っています
ねどういうものかというとこの散歩点があります
でそれぞれ辺がありますそれぞれの辺の垂直二等分線をぶつけて
でこのパターン左側のパターンができています
でこのパターンえっとこの真ん中で1点でも味わってますね
この垂直二等分線が3本あったときに1点で文字はこのてんてー
あの中学校の効かで皆さんあの懐かしいかなと思うんですけれどもやっとはずですね
これは外身です
つまりが維新の定理えっとこの三角形をに開始
雪する円の中心がでこの垂直二等分線が交わっ
ですが維新の定理があるので実はこれが折りたためて3つの定理が3つの点が一つの点
に集まるということになってますでこういう考え方を計算機科学今季停車ジオメトリー
の世界で拡張することができます
この拡張したずというのは follow ノイズてに呼ばれています
これは n 子
を点を与えた時にそれぞれの天皇がへ平面を支配している領域を表した図だという風に
考えられます
ということかというとある度領域っていうのはある点に対してのみ
最も近いと例えばコンビニが4つ平地にあって
であなたはどこのコンビが一番近いですかっていう広領域理由を下だと思っておられれ
ばいいですでこの頭を使うと実はこのおりスエット
ん
領域とルーキーを分けている境界線というのはですねこれはえーっ
やはり垂直二等分線あっているとなのでこれとこれを折るとお互い
10がくっついていくということで実はボロノイ図というのを計算してそれはにベース
にしてまた複雑なおりを加えていくんですけど少し区笹おりを加えていくとこういう形
でバラバラだった面が一箇所に集まってピタッと元の形を作ることができるだろうと
こういうことを考えたわけですね
でそれを感じ
作業って言ったということになりますこれやり方が分かりますとこれを計算することが
できるわけです
計算することができるということで実際プログラミングしてソフトウェアつくりました
これ俺は
マイザーというソフトとしてへと後悔しています
これあのウサギの形ですけどウサギも多面体なんですね三角形と四角形とができている
とそれがつながっていてそれをポンと入れるとその展開図を作ってくれるというわけ
です
でですねえっと
とこれがうまくいくかな
えっとこちらの方が右耳でこの辺が左海ですねこの辺が顔でその辺が背中という感じに
なってます
であのここまで出来たですねあとやることはですね
簡単であの居るだけです
でえっとまぁあの実はトリックが一つあってそれはコンピューターで生成した
おり生の放送なのでこれコンピューター制御のカッティングまっしーんって言って
まああのえっと神にエートス折り線をつけてくれるマシーンがありますのでそれを使っ
ており線をつけるでも最後居るのはもう手作業です
今動画を見ていただくとですねまぁあの
わかると思うんですけど背景の照明の色が集まったらどんどん変わっていくのがわかる
かなと思いますあのそのぐらい時間がだいたい10時間ぐらいよってこういう形で完成
します
私はこれをあーも発表した時にえっと質問があって本当にどんなものでも作れるんです
か
こうやって色んな物を作ってできるでしょって示したんですけどもその質問へへっ
どんなものでも作ればつまりおりがえっと造形をする形を作る手段
としての折り紙に異論的な限界が存在するのかしないのかと
こういう問いだったわけですこれは非常にあの面白い未解決の問題でこれは非常に
面白いなと思うことでえっと取り組むことになります
であのこの取り組みはですね mit のコンピューターサービスのエリックとメイン
さんとコラボレーションしてえっと
進めていきましたこれおりが前田の証明というのは未解決問題に挑んでいったんです
けども
えっ10年ほど図ったんですけどもつい先日この照明が完成して兄の多面体は凸多角形
の紙から水密な
釧路おり可能っていうことが分かりますつまりまぁ一言8そんなものですくれ
いうことになります
みなさんここまでお聞きなってですねちょっとこう思ったんじゃないかなと思うんです
ね
で後ですねあの私はこうワクワク感つまりその理論的なものを突き詰めるというところ
ワクワク感でえっと
この折り紙
こういう研究を進めてきたわけですねただまぁ社会的足専科メイトだこれは何役に立つ
脳ってことは多分
疑問だと思われますでまぁ難しいて話をしたんですけれども実はこのおりっていうのを
何丁かない関係解凍を繰り返していて正確に陥っている人たち達人がいるんですね
これは例えばですねあの
カブトムシの角っていうのがそんな気の前の段階でおられている状態を示したものです
でこれがサナギえっと脱皮して蛹になるときに pot 広がるんですね
このこういったおりっていうのが実は使われていると自然界では
えっと勝手に織り上がる自己組織化って言うんですけれどもえっと
人間えっと我々が人工物でものを作る時材料があってそれを作るための道具とか機会が
あって設計図がまたべきここにあってこれをうまく使って作るんですけど生物の形と
いうのはその材料の中に作る仕組みもあるしそれをえっと設計する設計図も入っている
わけですねそういったものが勝手に効果等
を交えながら作っていくとこういう仕組みにインスパイアされて何か作れないかという
ことを考えたのがこちらに
まえっと示した二郡という考え方ですつまり何か紙に絵パターンを印刷してそれを停止
レンジに入れてチンとしたら
中3次元の話が発展出来上がっているそういったことができないかなということを考え
ています
実際に
ですねあのマイクロスケールにおいては熱や光に反応してこう
勝手におり上がるような材料というのが開発されていますでこういうものが開発されて
いますので
ただまぁウサギは作れる段階にあるかというとまだなんでソーファ
えっと未解決の問題がたくさんあってそこを研究しています
平坦な状態かを立体になって立体から平坦になるということはあの折り紙を作るという
だけじゃなくて例えば建築の王様というのが考えられます例えば折りたたんでおいて
必要な時に開き開く
そういう仮説な建築物であるいは形を変えながら使えるようなものっていうのが作れる
んじゃないかということに想像が広がった
いくわけですねでそのそのためにはまた小動きの問題どうやってデザインするか動きを
どうやって理解するかみたいな事が必要になってそこにまた今未解決の問題がたくさん
できてくるとでそうするとですね
あの1枚の8まあ紙を折るというだけではなくていろんな問題が8出てきます
でえっとまぁ身近にある折り紙というものですけれども
えっとそこからいろんな未解決問題が出てきます
こちらですね
えっとを折りたたんだ状態から
パッと展開してこんな形にはですね
でこれはですねえっと折りたためる柔らかさって言うと構造的な強さ
建築で求められる構造的な強さというのを両立するにはどうしたらいいかということを
考えて作った放送ですこういう感じで新しいこと言うを見つけると正対する新しい答え
でそれ
今まで誰も見たことなかったような形っていうのが生まれてくるわけです
そういう形でその折り紙っていうのはえっとまぁ身近な遊びですね身近な遊びである
折り紙というものにも人類未踏の領域というのがを含まれていてす方法
我々一生懸命探索しているわけです
今日はご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]